- This UCSD-TV program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn? Visit our website or
follow us on Facebook and Twitter to keep
up with the latest programs.
- We are the paradoxical ape, bipedal,
naked, large brain, long the master of
fire, tools and language but still trying
to understand ourselves. Aware that death
is inevitable, yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly, we hand down knowledge,
we empathize and deceive, we shape the
future from our shared understanding of
the past. CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines to exchange
insights on who we are and how we got
here, an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
- Thanks very much and thanks to all of
you for coming. It's wonderful to be here
and talk to such an incredible audience. I
thought I'd start off by posing a question
that I think is particularly relevant to
all of us thinking about language
evolution. And that's, what's so special
about language? In a sense, the goal of
evolutionary linguistics, is to try and
explain the origins of the special
properties of language. And there are two
that I want to focus on today. And in
fact, Roger started with one of them. So
first off, I want to highlight structure.
Language has a highly unusual and rich
systematic structure
in the way it's put together.
So when I say the phrase two boots, you're
able to relate the acoustic wave-form that
hits your ears and to this rather cute
picture of my son's shoes on this slide.
Now, how are you able to do that? You are
able to do that because of the special
structure that language has. The signals
that we produce are constructed sequences
of these meaningless elements, we call
them phonemes. So these different phonemes
are put together in different ways, we
organize them in different ways to make up
the sounds of our language and sequences.
But furthermore, these meaningless
elements are themselves put together to
make morphemes, the meaning-carrying
elements of language.
And these are put together to construct
meaningful holes. So you understand what
two boots means because you understand
these ways in which language recombines
elements. And it's because of this
recombination, because we can endlessly
recombine elements of these two different
levels, that we are able to talk about
anything. So we're able to constantly
reproduce completely new utterances with
the happy expectation that everyone can
understand this. This is an incredible
feat and remarkably, it seems to be unique
to our species. So that was one of the
special features of language structure.
So next up, the other one I want to talk
about is learning. So we are able to use
language because we have learned both how
to produce the signals in our language and
we've also learned, perhaps even more
remarkably, what the signals in our
language mean. So we're able to use
language meaningfully because we've
observed language being used around us as
we grow up. Again, this combination of
learning, this signal and learning the
meaning seems to be unique in nature. What
I'm particularly interested in, is the
fact that this is a very
particular kind of learning.
When we learn language, we're learning
from the product of other people who've
gone through the same learning process.
So we learn from the observation of the
output of other learners. So this is
something that I call iterated learning.
It's a particular and relatively unusual
process in nature. So what iterated
learning means is that the language I
speak, I learned by observing language
being produced by my parents and the
language I produce is going on to affect
the language that my son and
daughter are acquiring.
So what this means is that we have this
process of cultural transmission of
language through this mapping from
external production of language and some
internal representation of language. And
what this means is that language is
evolved. So this is a kind of cultural
evolution. Language itself is an
evolutionary system in its own right. What
I want to suggest today is that these two
features, structure and iterated learning
are related to each other. And in fact,
what I want to claim is that language
structure is the inevitable consequence of
the fact that language is a culturally
evolving system.
So I want to try and pose it onto this
question affirmatively, that cultural
evolution can explain why language has the
structure that it does. So how on earth
could we go about answering this question?
This is one of the challenges of doing
evolutionary linguistics, is how on earth
do you study it scientifically? There are
lots of ways and you're going to hear
about a lot of them today. One of the ways
that we pioneered my lab in Ettenberg, was
to try and recreate language evolution,
the cultural evolution of
language in the experiment lab.
So I'm going to show you how we do that.
I'm going to give you two examples of two
experiments that we've done. It will give
you a flavor of the way in which we can
study cultural evolution of language in
the lab. So generally, how do we do this?
What we did is, we brought together two
kind of expanded experimental techniques
from two different areas. One was a
paradigm from psycholinguistics called
artificial language learning, where we get
participants into the lab and teach them
miniature languages, and then test them.
And another technique from experimental
anthropology, I guess you'd call it
transmission chain paradigm and this is a
way people study the process of cultural
evolution in various different domains. So
we just plug in those two together. So
I'll talk you through in general, how it
works, and then I'll give you the two
specific examples. So first off, we bring
our participants into the lab and we ask
them to learn a miniature language. And
so, this is a very, very small miniature
artificial language that we've created. So
we might have them in the lab for an hour,
maximum, and then we test them. So we get
them to produce utterances in this
miniature language.
At this stage, this is the standard
paradigm artificial language but the twist
we put on it is that we used the output of
that participant when we test them, to
form the language that the next
participant in the lab is going to learn
from. And then, we take the output of that
second participant and use that to form
the input training data for the third
participant in the lab and so on. So, we
create a chain of transmission of this
miniature language and watched how it
evolves as it passes from participant to
participant in our experiments.
What we typically do is we start with
language in scare quotes
that is random and unstructured and
doesn't have these structural properties
that we're interested in. And then we want
to see if those structural properties
emerge through this process of
transmission over these artificial
generations that we've created in the lab
experiments. Okay, so that's the general
structures of this experimental approach,
and I'm going to give you two examples. So
here's the first example, this is a joint
work with Hannah Cornish and Kenny Smith,
picture there, and this is our first
experiment, the first experiment that we
did in our lab. And so this,
as you can see, 2008, this is
a relatively recent approach that we've
been taking here. And what we wanted to do
is look for this emergence of
compositional structures.
Compositional structure is the idea that
you can put words together to make
meanings. So the meaning of a whole
expression is made up of the meanings of
parts of that expression. So I wanted to
see if we could get back to
emerge in these lab experiments.
So what participants did, so we have this
kind of experimental chain of participants
and what the participants were asked to do
was learn a miniature language, and the
language was made up of these weird
meanings, which were just colored shapes
that were moving in different ways. And we
had three colors and three shapes and
three different types of movement. So
three, times three, times three, that
makes 27 different possible meanings
in this language.
So when I say miniature language, I really
mean miniature. These pictures, these
meanings were paired with strings of
syllables and these were just made up at
random by the computer. This is a
completely unstructured arbitrary
language, every single meaning was given a
different label. And each participant was
trained on half of the language but then
was tested on all of the meanings.
So they were trained on half of the
meanings, but then were asked to produce
strings of syllables for all of the
meanings when we tested them. And then
there I put then forms of input for the
next participant in the lab. And again, we
took a random half of the first
participant to train the second one and
then test the second one and then take
another random half of their language to
train the third participant and so on down
the chain. So what happens?
Well, what we find is that the people are
absolutely terrible at this task. So, this
graph shows error and it's rather a
forgiving measure of error, an error of
one would mean that you've got not a
single character, not a single letter
right, in the target word.
An error of zero
means you got everything right. And
what you see here is four different runs
of the experiment and each point on this
graph is a different participant. So, the
first participant in the lab had a really
terrible time. In fact, nobody got a
single word exactly right, it's empty,
absolutely awful. By the end, however, the
participants in the later generations in
these chains, some of them were getting
everything exactly right, including the
meanings that they weren't trained on.
So they were successfully guessing the
correct label for meanings that we didn't
even train them on. So how on earth is
that happening? Well, I'll show you what
the languages look like as they evolve. So
here's an initial random language, for
example, this table, the word manikin is
the word for a blue square that's moving
horizontally. Now, bear in mind, you're
trained in half of this language, imagine
if I blanked out half of these words and
then I asked you to reconstruct the
missing words, then you'd have no hope.
You couldn't possibly get it right because
this is random. So, if you didn't know
that that word was miniki, there's no way
you could guess it. So that's why they're
doing so badly. And this is what that same
language looks like ten generations later.
So now you see how the participants are
doing this. So, now, if I blanked off half
of those words, you'll be able to
successfully guess what the missing words
were. For example, the word poi now refers
to all spiraling objects.
So this language has evolved to become
more easy to learn but it's evolved in a
very, very slightly disappointing way from
our point of view. So it's evolved just by
jettisoning words in a particular way, so
that these words refer to particular
sections of the set of meanings. So why is
it happening? In fact there's some
versions of the experiment we go down to a
single word for all things.
So, clearly, we need something else in
this experiment. We need some kind of
pressure to be expressive as well as
learnable for the language. I can't go
into the details, we don't have time, but
what we essentially did was we added in a
filter on the output of each participant.
So we threw out items that were ambiguous
before we passed it on to the next
participant. None of the participants
could be aware that we were doing this
manipulation. So we ran the whole
experiment again with this extra hidden
step and we got completely different
results. So, here's again, another initial
language again, completely random. And
now, ten generations later, it looks quite
different. Now, what I've done here is I
added in hyphens to make it easier for you
to see, but the participants don't get to
see these hyphens, right.
What you see here is that different parts
of the signals correspond to different
parts of the meanings. So for example,
this n prefix means the black things, the
r prefix means red things, a plo suffix
means something that's bouncing and so on.
So this is the compositionality we're
looking for and it emerged down to this
process of cultural transmission. So
structure seems to emerge spontaneously
from this process of cultural evolution.
Now, a couple of obvious worries that you
might have, so firstly, perhaps the
participants in our experiment are kind of
deliberately thinking, "Well, this
language is rubbish, here's how we can fix
it up, we'll add some structure."
Well, you don't think that's what's
happening because, bear in mind, these two
different runs of experiment are very
different languages but the participants
couldn't know which condition they were
in. Now, the possible objection is, "Well,
okay that they already speak a language. "
In fact, all of our participants spoke
English. So, it's not surprising that they
gradually changed the system to be one
that looks more like a language. Well,
that's a valid worry, so we've recreated
all of this experiment in a computer
simulation, where we can know that our
computational participants don't have a
pre-existing language and we get the same
results. So that's my first example.
The second example, and we wanted to move
away from this starting point with these
random strings because that seems to be a
bit weird, where do they come from? And
instead, we start from potentially much
more natural starting point, one of
gestural pantomime. And we wanted to see
if we could evolve structured, something
that looks like a structured sign
language, miniature structured sign
language out of the initial state that was
iconic pantomime.
And this is joint work with Kenny Smith,
Katya Brumifer, and Erica Cartmill.
So here's how the experiment works. So, in
this version of the experiment, the
meanings now are videos of a bouncing
ball, so here's one. That's the things
that have to be conveyed and the signals
are manual gestures made to a video
camera, so, something like this. And the
initial language in this experiment was
improvised one off pantomimes that we got
people into the lab and just said, "Okay
can you give the pantomime that
corresponds to this video?"
Participants are trained on 12 out of the
16 videos, but asked to produce gestures
for all 16. And then the
same process of this
diffusion chain, transmission chain we
supplied. So we'd see how the gestures of
all of the generations. I'll just show you
the four sets of meanings, it's a little
bit alarming when you see it. So these are
all the different videos tied together,
and what you can see here is there is
different paths in which the ball moves
along, so flat, sloping, in an S shape, or
in a circle. And there are different
manners that the ball might be bouncing or
rolling or spinning or giving this
nightmarish, gesturing motion. So that's
the set of meanings they have to convey.
This is what the initial pantomimes look
like for all the participants we got in
just to do one off the gestures for these.
And what you see here is there's a huge
range of different strategies that people
use to produce these meanings.
There's an enormous diversity in
strategies here. So what we were
interested in, some of them are more
successful than others.
What we're interested in is how do these
strategies evolve down generations. So
here's our first participant who saw 12 of
these and then produced a gesture for each
of them. Now, it looks more systematic
because it's one person, so they all look
a little bit more similar. In fact,
there's still a lot of diversity here if
you look at the handshake used to convey
the ball and so on, there's still a lot of
diversity. And much later in the same
chain, we have this participant.
Now, it's looking much more systematic.
There is, if you look at handshake for
example, it's now very similar across all
the different videos and there are
particular kinds of systematicity we're
interested in. So here's an example from
another chain, which I particularly like,
and have a look at what she's doing here
to convey the ball moving.
So she signals the ball and says the
manner and then the path. So she separated
out two aspects of this meaning
compositionally into two different parts.
And indeed, another interesting thing that
she does here, she self-corrects. She
says, "Oh no, I got it wrong" and watch
again, she'll do it again. This indicates
that at this point in this evolution of
language, she's seeing that there's a
right and wrong answer, it's become
grammatically. Just to summarize these,
then I'll be done. So over time, the
gestures in this language become less
pantomimic and more conventional. And we
can actually measure this, we can show the
systematic structure emerges over
generations in this experiment.
And interestingly, the separation of
manner and path, mirrors what we can see
in real emerging sign languages. So this
is work by Anne Senghas and colleagues,
looking at how in Nicaraguan sign language
and emerging sign language we get the
separation of manner and path emerging
over generations, over cohorts. So, final
conclusions, I want to argue that language
is an evolutionary system in its own right
and because of this, languages adapt and
they adapt to path more easily from
learner to learner. And linguistic
structure is the solution that cultural
evolution finds the problem at being
learnable. So it's an inevitable
consequence of the way language is
transmitted and we can and indeed we
should study this process in the
experiment lab. Thank you very much.
- Thank you and thank you very much for
the invitation to join you today.
As speakers of English when we
hear constructions like get 'em
bring 'em, take 'em, we analyze those
as a verb and a pronoun, get them or get
him, bring them or bring him. This
analysis is supported by the fact that we
read and write, we rarely see the informal
forms written so usually the formal forms.
And through schooling, which generally
tell us to use the formal forms and to
leave the others alone but we also know
when it's appropriate to use which style
in which context. We're now going to move
to a different context where speakers
heard those constructions but
analyze them differently.
When Australia was colonized, there were
about 250 languages spoken by indigenous
people. The speakers of the Australian
languages and the English speakers had to
learn to communicate with each other very
quickly. Usually, the English speakers
didn't learn much of the Australian
languages. The onus was on the indigenous
people to learn as much English as they
could to get by with. So let's imagine
that English speakers were using the
informal constructions a lot when they
were speaking, take 'em over there,
bring 'em back, constructions like
that we use all the time
without thinking about it.
The speakers of the Australian language
who hadn't yet learned English, identify
the pattern in what they are hearing. When
they heard verbs like get, bring, take,
they frequently heard something like mm,
occurring after the verb but they didn't
hear that when the verb was something like
walk, which doesn't have a direct object.
So they came to analyze the mm that we
would think of as a pronoun as being a
grammatical element that attaches to a
transitive verb, it's a verb with an
object but not to verbs like walk and run.
They didn't have literacy or schooling to
influence their analysis, they just made
this analysis from identifying patterns in
the language being spoken to them and what
they heard around them. So the transitive
mm or the transitive marker is a new
structure that came into that system that
was not the same as the structure that was
already in English and it was not in the
Australian languages either but we can see
where it came from. But the Australian
languages did influence that structure in
abstract ways. The form of in, is clearly
from English, but there are other
influences from the Australian languages,
I've just listed a few of them here.
One is, for example, the inverse
languages, when you have a transitive verb
construction, it's a different
construction from an intransitive verb.
So those speakers learn to pay attention
to the transitivity of the verb in every
clause because that was required by the
grammar. So it made sense to them based on
their first languages to have a different
construction for a transitive versus an
intransitive verb. In addition, there were
rules for words and the sound systems
within the language that the Australian
verbs didn't suit very well and the new
analysis suited them better.
So for example, words in Australian
languages often, at least two syllables
long, if you have a short verb, adding the
transitive marker, made it longer and
conformed more to the rules of the first
languages. Similarly, words in Australian
languages in that area didn't usually end
with a cluster of consonants at the end of
the word. So again, adding that marker
made the word shape conform more to the
type of word that speakers of those
languages were used to. The in structure
is a good example of some
characteristics of a pidgin.
The word forms come mostly from the
language spoken by the socially-dominant
group, which we call the lexophile
language but a lot of the structure and
word meanings come from the other multiple
languages that were being spoken by the
creators. In addition, reanalysis take
place such as what we've just seen through
pattern finding processes and second
language learning processes. A pidgin is a
means of intergroup communication, you use
it to speak to people whose language you
don't know, and all of those speakers were
still using their own first languages when
I spoke to people within the same group.
The pidgins spread throughout Australia as
English speakers spread throughout
Australia. And in each place, there were
Australian languages and those speakers
were contributing features to the new
system. Indigenous people were brought
together in groups and needed to interact
with speakers of many other languages with
whom traditionally, they wouldn't have
interacted much or at all. So they all
needed a way to speak to each other.
And this system was a good
system to build on in order to do that.
As speakers needed to talk about more and
more topics with each other, more and more
elements were added from English and also
from the Australian languages. Varieties
of Northern territory Creole were derived
from interactions of this kind.
Here's an example,
[foreign language]
And you can see there the transitive
marker on the verb which came in via
pidgin. There's another interesting
element there which is been,
meaning past tense. Again, the form is
from English, have been
had been but there's another
reanalysis there named simple past tense,
it's not part of the have been or had been
construction. Research suggest that
there's more than one developmental path
for Creole language, but this is one
tested path. Again, the word forms come
mostly from the socially-dominant
language, English but much of the
structure in the word meanings come from
the other input languages. In this case,
there was an earlier pidgin that fed into
the Creole. Reanalysis took place through
pattern finding and second language
learning processes and the system expanded
and developed.
There was a prior pidgin that was used for
intergroup communication. A creole is the
first language of its speakers and is a
full language. This variety of creole
continued to develop and stabilize,
probably often until about the 1940s and
1950s and it currently has several
varieties. We'll turn now to another kind
of context language in another setting in
Australia. This is in a small ball pre-
community in the Northern territory. In
this community, speakers over about the
age of 35, mostly speak Warlpiri, their
traditional language but they also code
switch into a varieties of English
and Creole.
Code-switching is switching between
languages in a single conversation. And by
aboriginal English there, I mean English
with elements of the indigenous languages
and elements of Creole in it. Younger
speakers, younger adults and children,
speak in a new way which systematically
combines elements from those sources which
we call light Warlpiri. Children learn to
speak this language from when they first
begin to talk. As they grow older
they also produce
Warlpiri and then code switch into the
English-based varieties. The children now
learn light Warlpiri and Warlpiri from
there. We'll look at a little background
structure of the contributing languages
before we look at the
structure of light Warlpiri.
[foreign language]
- As you can see there, Warlpiri is a
suffixing language. A lot of the
grammatical functions are indicated
through suffixes on words. We can also see
here the difference between the transitive
and intransitive construction that I
mentioned earlier that the pidgin creators
paid attention to.
The word therefore, child, she's doing the
chasing and the monster who's doing the
taking, have a suffix on them that doesn't
occur on nouns when there's an
intransitive verb like walk. So it's in
that way that these constructions are
quite different. And in contrast,
varieties of English and Creole indicate
grammatical functions, mostly through
separate words and with fairly fixed word
order. So how do these languages combine
in this new system like Warlpiri?
[foreign language]
- You might notice that there are English
verbs that come and go. Much of the verb
system of light Warlpiri is from
aboriginal English and Creole verb
structure, but not entirely. If you look
at example three, there's
actually a Warlpiri verb stem but it has
the Creole transitive marker on it. So the
overall structure is derived from those
languages. You can say that the Warlpiri's
suffixing. So we have the verbal structure
mostly from aboriginal English and Creole
but we have all of the noun structure
retained from Warlpiri. But in the verbal
structure, there were also innovations
which are indicated in green
The wim and the yum and they're what we're
most interested in today. This pattern of
verbal structure from one source and noun
structure from another source is fairly
unusual in the world's languages.
The differences between Warlpiri and light
Warlpiri are in the verb and auxiliary
structure which have these clearly
different forms that the underlying
abstract structure is more complicated. So
the wim and yum, constructions which are
the innovations are part of an overall
system, much of which already existed in
Creole and aboriginal English. You can see
there that for each word, there's a
pronoun element like we, you, a, which is
from I and then there's another element,
which mostly means time.
So where did this wim and yum construction
come from? We know that it's not something
that comes from English. Well, it seems
that the mm came from English, I'm, like
the form but there's also an mm in the
aboriginal English and Creole pronouns in
and them. Through this process of creating
this structure, they will reanalyze, so
that, instead of being a pronoun on 'em or
them, there were a new structure where
they would divide it into two parts.
Aboriginal English and Creole has this
past mark have been and that really occurs
in light Warlpiri. So instead of using
that, what has happened, is that the
speakers have taken the past meaning from
been and overlaid it on the mm element
from aboriginal English and Creole, such
that they have this new structure where
the mm is a separate morpheme with it's
own meaning that means present or past or
non future and then that is regularized
across the system, and you have a new
paradigm. Another example.
[foreign language]
- That was some kids playing a card game
for me and using that structure there.
So what are the influences on the new
structure? Again, we see that the words
shape or form comes from the varieties of
English or Creole but the structure and
the meaning comes from multiple sources.
In Warlpiri, the auxiliary has a structure
where there's a time element, which is the
kah meaning present
and a pronoun element. And
you can say that all through the system
these are affixes, they're not separate
words.
So I think that this underlying structure
of wanting a time element and pronoun
element affixed together with part of the
influence that fade into the new system.
In Warlpiri, the verb and the auxiliary
forms combine in different kinds of
constructions to give the same kinds of
semantic readings as we find in light
Warlpiri. So in the final column, those
three meanings of non-future, future,
and disiterative are exactly the
categories that we find in light Warlpiri.
But they're not structural categories in
Warlpiri, they're semantic categories. And
again, have been overlaid onto the forms
in light Warlpiri. So how did the whole
language come to be? They were through a
two-step process when the adult groups who
are now about 35 years old were children,
I think that other adults spoke to them in
what is known as a baby talk register and
in that register, they code-switched a lot
and they code-switched in a particular
pattern. So it would be something like
this, where there will be a Warlpiri
sentence but they would insert a Creole
pronoun and verb into that sentence.
And that is the pattern that the children
then conventionalized by analyzing it as a
single system. At the same time, they
added the innovations that we've just been
talking about. That group of children, who
I think do this maybe when they were
three, four or five, certainly before they
were teenagers, they then grew up, had
children of their own, and so now those
children learn that language as one of
their first languages along with Warlpiri
and that's their primary language.
The path to this language is a
little different.
It wasn't created for intergroup
communication. It was created within one
group of people in one community and it's
only spoken within that group of people in
that community. The speakers were
multilingual, there was a lot of
code-switching, it was directed to very
young children in a particular pattern.
They then conventionalized it and
re-analyzed some of the input that they
were hearing and then regularized their
analysis to create new paradigms.
From English and Creole, we get words and
a lot of verb structure. From Warlpiri we
get words, the noun structure and also
abstract verbal structure. And this new
system is the first language of the
current generations. So, what we've been
able to see, almost in real times, is a
new language developed and an innovative
structure in that language, through a
two-step process. Adults had their fairly
systematic code-switching in the speech
that they were directing to children and
then the children had a very creative role
in conventionalizing their input and
adding the innovations.
The overall structure is unusual because
it combines the noun structure from one
type of language with the verb structure
for another. And there are these
innovations which are interesting in that,
we can see exactly where they've come
from, we can see exactly where the
re-analysis would have taken place and we
can see that at the end of that
reanalysis, there is a new construction.
Thank you.
- If you go to Nicaragua today, you can
see these deaf children hanging out in
their school playground using a rich
natural sign language to communicate. And
40 years ago, this language didn't exist,
40 years ago, deaf children in Nicaragua,
children just like these kids, didn't have
the ability to communicate effortlessly
with one another like they do. So, how did
this language get into the hands of these
children? If we think about that, we
really have to think about
where does any
language come from?
Language is really central to human
nature, it's universal. Not every
community has writing or numbers or even
real but every community, ever human
community has language. Language is not
something we've discovered out there in
the world, language has come, they're a
product from us, humans connecting and
interacting in a social network generation
after generation. So, to see where this
language came from, I'm going to take you
on a little journey and retrace the path
of Nicaraguan sign language
up to the present day.
When these children arrived at school five
years ago, there were already about 1200
deaf native users of Nicaraguan sign
language and there were hundreds of kids
older than them using this language around
them in their school. These children
learned it from interacting with them.
Now, if we want to know what those
hundreds of kids who were older than that
current day generation of children, what
they looked like, we can look at the kids
who were teenagers at the time when they
entered. So, this first group here entered
the school in the mid 1990s and at that
time, there were about 800 signers of
Nicaraguan sign language and 200 of them
were at the school at any time.
You can see that it's fast, it's fluent,
they can talk about the non here and now.
This is a natural human language that's
used for what human languages are used
for. And if we want to know where they got
their language from we can retrace the
steps of the language further back when
these kids were four and five years old
and ask who were the teenagers then when
they arrived at school?
So we can look at the people who were 10
years older than them, when these guys,
these are the cohort that arrived in the
1980s. So when they arrived, there were
about 400 signers of Nicaraguan sign
language, again, 200 at the school. If you
have an eye for it, you may be able to see
how, as we're going further and further
back, the language is a little bit more
deliberate, the feedback is a little more
explicit and the signs are bigger and
more symmetrical than more two-handed
signs and lots of differences like that. A
lot of the work that I do is to try and
quantify what those differences are.
If you wanted to know who they got their
language from, to continue this retracing
of the steps, when they arrived at the
school, the older people were these people
who are 45 to 50 years old today and when
these people were four and five years old
in the 1970s and they first came to the
school, there were no signers of
Nicaraguan sign language and this is where
we reach the end of our retracing. Nobody
taught these people to sign. The
teachers at the school used Spanish, which
they couldn't hear and so this is where
Enocell begins with this cohort of 50
pioneers. They took the gestures and
actions that they observed as raw
materials and wove them into
a new language.
So we have this incredible opportunity to
see how languages are born and evolve and
the role that language learners play in
that evolution and I'm going to start with
the language of this earliest first cohort
of signers and walk forward to the present
day. And start with the most
fundamental pieces
of the grammar that every language has,
the structure of the simple statement. So
arguments and predicates, how do you show
who's doing what to whom? So in English
for example, we use word order to do this.
So if you take a sentence like "A man taps
a woman," and you change the order of the
words "A woman taps a man," you change
who is doing the tapping and who gets
tapped. Now, other languages might stick
inflectional endings on the end of the
verbs or even on the nouns to show which
person is the tapper and which the tappee
is. And to figure this out, my colleagues
and I use non-verb materials to illicit
sentences that can compare these different
aspects of the sentence. So, I'll show you
how different signers
respond to stimuli like these.
So an event like this giving event or
this tapping event and here is what the
first cohort sentence looks like. They
have a very strict noun, verb, noun, verb
word order. So, to say that a woman taps a
man, you have woman, tap and man tapped.
And here's what this looks like when a
first cohort signer signs it. So I want
you to see how he produces that noun,
verb, noun, verb order for signing who
tapped, the sign for woman, which is
produced like this and
who is tapped, his sign for man.
So, he's going to sign these nouns, man
and woman and in the neutral area in front
of his chest, and note that there is this
movement in the verbs away from and toward
the body the way they can reflect
iconically, the way that movement happens
in the world but they are centered in the
signer's body. He keeps his body centered
and neutral. And so, here is what it looks
like "woman, tap, man get tapped." So,
this all very nice and clear and orderly.
But the interesting thing that it wasn't
reproduced this way in the next second
cohorts. So, starting in about 1983 or
'84, the second wave of kids who were
coming in took this direction in which
signs are produced and started giving that
a job in the grammar. And what they did
was they started modifying where they
produced their signs as a way of showing
who did what to whom. So in this example
in the first panel, we have the words see
and pay produced in this neutral area in
front of the chest and in the second panel
you can see that the signs have been
modified so the direction is to the left.
So, if these signs were together in one
sentence, produced by a second cohort
signer, it would mean that the same person
was both see and paid. So, these
inflections started out with the verbs
like this but soon after, in the mid 80s,
you can also start producing nouns in
particular locations to link them to verbs
and more recently, you can even use it
just to point to one location or another
to refer to the person associated with
that location. So, now you're using these
locations in space, not to talk about
where something happened but to show who's
involved. So we'll see, here is an example
that a second cohort signer does and you
can see how these developments
really changed the
basic structure of the sentence.
So, here is the woman giving to the man
event and you'll see you get the nouns now
being produced in particular locations
that correspond with the direction of
movement and the verbs to show you what
the object or recipient is. And notice
that with the addition of the special
modification on the signs, we find there
came in changes of the word, so now, the
verbs move to the end of the sentence. So
you are going to see, first she talks
about, you remember those three people in
that scene? So, she starts talking about
the woman on the right, just looking
straight ahead, then she
touches her chest.
That's a switch reference device and then
you'll see she does woman, man, your nouns
and then gives, receive your verbs. Woman
look and then self, woman, man, give
receive. And now, if we move to the third
cohort, we're going to see the
introduction of the space you all use with
points linking the verbs
with the doer and the done to.
So this an event where a woman pushes
another woman, a woman in a black shirt
and a woman in a green shirt. So he's
going to index the black shirt to his left
and the woman in green to the right. And
then come the verbs, remember, they're at
the end, push, be pushed and finally,
you'll see this verb respect at the end.
And what I love about this example, the
respect sign here, is that even though
respect isn't something that moves from
one person to another and nor is telling,
here we're going to see the space and the
movement of the verb linking it to the
nouns. So you can say green tells black
that black should show green some respect
and you do that all with one
word using the space.
So black, green, push, be pushed, respect,
see. Okay. So, we can measure this
restructuring in many ways and here's one.
If you plot how frequently points are used
in that way that shows who, rather than
where, you get this pattern. So, starting
on the left with home signers who are deaf
people who are never exposed to a sign
language and then the first, second and
third cohorts you can see that they all
use points to where about the same amount
that something stay pretty stable. But
this nominal use, this use that shows who,
that's linking the noun with the verbs,
this has really increased with the second
and third cohorts of signers, so, the
questions of, why this change?
And if children are so good at learning
language and someone has already developed
a perfectly good way to mark subjects and
objects, why didn't the second cohort just
learn to sign it the same way the first
cohort had been doing it. I mean, it's one
thing to gradually to drop whom from your
English but this is a total restructuring
of the language here. To answer that
question, I think we really need to take
seriously, this idea of
language as an organism.
Language is an organism, so, this isn't
just a metaphor for when we say, a
language is an abstract thing. It's
abstract but it's still real, it's a
bundle of structured material and it's
self-replicating and we each live in a
symbiotic relationship with our language,
like the microbes in our gut. We can't
survive without it and it can't survive
without us. And language changes and
adapts to the humans that host it. So, the
social network of people that learn it and
pass it on are the environment in which
language evolves.
Now, the different versions of Nicaraguan
sign language that we see signed by
different age cohorts today represent this
living record of the evolutionary path of
the language. And so, the way that I have
been doing my work, the way I have
described is, I look at this slice today.
If you start with the 1970s with this
figure over to the left and then you have
the first cohort coming in and in the 80s,
the second cohort joins them and then the
third and fourth, we can look at today at
the difference between the cohorts.
But we can't forget that the action, the
moment of change, is over there. It's as
we add each new wave and that's where the
language and that's when the language
reproduces. So the first cohort builds the
language as children in the 70's and then
they pass it on to this next cohort in the
80s and that second cohort acquires it
with some fidelity but they
don't copy it exactly.
And so, on in the 90s and today, and we
know these changes occurred when they're
children because the path is
unidirectional. So, stuff can get passed
on to later cohorts but not the other way.
It doesn't go back. So, things that adult
initiate or learn, they would be the same
for everyone. And there are things like
that that you see that are the same across
all of the cohorts. But these core aspects
of the grammar how the sentence is
structured, how you do agreement, how you
show who is doing what to whom. Those
kinds of things, they're changing in just
that one direction and they don't get
passed on back up.
So this chain from one to two then is
where that, where it got reinterpreted as
who. So to take our question about why
change it, we have to really think about
how languages replicate, what's the
mechanism that copies that code, the rules
and patterns of Nicaraguan sign language
and passes it on to the next iteration of
inner self because just because the
organism that say, 1980s NSL developed
some cool characteristic, doesn't mean you
get to pass it on for free. If we don't
have a really good understanding of the
mechanism of reproduction, what we'll
start to see parallels between development
and evolution that don't actually explain
the nature of the change.
So, most of us are more familiar with
Lamarc's second law here, this idea that
adaptations made by an organism in
response to its environment get inherited
by its offspring. So the sons of the
blacksmith must have bigger biceps or the
daughter of the giraffe gets a slightly
longer neck than her mother started with
but Lemarc also had this first law that,
as much as we developed from simple cells
to complex systems that all organisms have
a natural drive to complexify.
And these are great ideas but they don't
worked out. They don't work out because
now, we know that reproduction doesn't
work that way. You don't just pass down
the useful stuff or the more complex stuff
or the exercised parts. And what we've
learned from Darwin and since Darwin is
that we have to pay attention to
reproduction and selection processes.
Organisms send along everything, they send
down everything, not just the useful stuff
but they do it with variability and noise.
So the environment is what's determining
what will survive.
So now, we really have two evolutionary
processes on really, really different time
scales. We've got human reproduction and
selection on one hand and language
reproduction and selection on the other.
It's not that one recapitulates the other,
it's each of them is evolving and is
shaped by the processes of reproduction
and selection. In human reproduction, we
pass on what are the patterns we can learn
and it may be very slowly and very long
ago that more effective and more powerful
pattern-learning devices would prevail.
But we all came into the world with brains
that are a product of that process. On the
other hand, when language is reproduced,
they send out all these accumulated
symbols and patterns of combinations but
it's a blurry and limited signal
and it's just the output of someone's own
language and it isn't copied perfectly. In
the process of selection, it's not the
useful stuff but the learnable parts of
the language that survive. So what we've
got then, is this co-evolution of humans
and their languages. Each of them is
serving as the environment for the other
and each cannot survive without the other.
The thing is though, that we don't set out
to create languages, to grow languages,
this isn't done with an intention to make
a code. Humans grow languages because our
social connection is so critical. When we
pass a language from one generation to the
next, the goal isn't to create something
or to organize your message.
The goal is to connect and the drive is a
social one. The idea is to get your
message into someone else's mind and to
understand what message someone else is
sending to your mind. And in that process
of communicating back and forth and
actually forth and forth, that's how we
use the fabric of language with the
machinery of our minds.
So, thank you very much.